I was just putting the dog together
to go out and
then I get the message on Twitter hey are
you in Berlin from Frank Marches,
that's my colleague at the C Institute and
he says are you in Berlin do
you have a webcam
or if you  out and then I said
I'm going out now my dog ​​then says he
takes the cell phone with him take the cell phone with him
because here I can tell you exactly at
032 a.m. UTC so at 1:32 a.m. Berlin
time there's
a shooting star coming down
or a meteor  and I knew I did
n't even know at the time, as I
said, it wasn't in the area
that we can now predict exactly what's going to happen minutes ago
and I've now
made myself smart, this is the eighth time
that this has even been possible,
because normally
You simply don't discover these small bodies beforehand,
they were only 1 m tall, which means that
usually
nothing falls on the ground at that size, but now that's
apparently different with this one, my
other colleague Richard Meusel at
ESA  said that the
speed they calculated
is so low that the
heat development is so low that
everything doesn't burn up, which means that
parts can also fall to the ground and
the real species are probably already
on the move in Havelland  and and are looking for a few parts
so we actually get
a lot of material every day, I
also checked again 40 to
100 tons is the um the
assessment is that W so much material
everyone after wars and actually
it is  1 m size is very common,
so the smaller it is, the less
you can see. The larger it is,
the more material is gasified and burns
up